hi it's michelle from lab muffin beauty
science chemistry phd skin care nerd and big
fan of sunscreen today i'm going to be talking
about the do's and don'ts of sunscreens what
should you and shouldn't you do this video is
sponsored by adore beauty australia's biggest
online-only beauty retailer they sell lots of face
sunscreens including some of my personal favorites
stick around because i'm going to be
going through some of those at the end
i've also got adore beauty's jo fleming
to talk about some of her favorites too
you might know her from the beauty iq
uncensored podcast i have oily skin and jo
has drier skin so between us we've probably got
you covered for a good sunscreen recommendation
we also did a sunscreen q & a that's posted on
the adore beauty channel so check that out too
if you like finding out more about the science
behind beauty products click the like the
subscribe and click the nerdification bell so you
don't miss any videos alright let's get into it
firstly do wear sunscreen daily sunscreen isn't
just for the beach if you're serious about skin
care you should be wearing sunscreen every day
there is a bit of wiggle room here if the uv index
is below 3 then according to australian medical
authorities you don't have to wear sunscreen
but since you're here watching a skincare
video you probably care about sun damage
and you're probably using some
anti-aging ingredients in your skin care
so unless you want to be wasting all of
that hard work and money then you should
be probably wearing sunscreen every day some
anti-aging ingredients like alpha hydroxy acids
also make your skin more sensitive to the sun
and so that makes wearing daily sunscreen more
of a priority daily sunscreen might even be
important if you work indoors near a window
there are longer uv rays called uva
rays and these still penetrate through
glass and even though they don't cause burning
they do cause premature aging i have another
video about how to work out if you need sunscreen
indoors and i'll link that in the description
do wear enough sunscreen the first rule
of sunscreen club is use enough sunscreen
a little goes a long way is a lie when it comes
to sunscreen the less sunscreen you have on your
skin the less protection you get you can think of
sunscreen like paint if you don't have enough on
you're not hiding your skin well enough from the
sun the standard recommendation for face sunscreen
is a quarter teaspoon or two finger lengths
and that's like two generous-ish finger lengths
when in doubt apply more you're going to need more
than a thin layer to get enough sun protection
do wear sunscreen under makeup all sunscreens
chemical physical or even combo go on your skin
at the end of your skincare routine so this means
it goes over any serums or creams you're using
and under your makeup so that includes
primer foundation concealer blush
it's a myth that you need to apply chemical
and physical sunscreens differently
chemical sunscreens don't need to react
with your skin to activate or anything
but both types of sunscreens need some time
to form an even layer on your skin getting
this nice even smooth layer is how you get
even sun protection it's a bit like how you
need to wait a little bit for wall paint
to flatten out and for the brush strokes to
disappear after you've applied your sunscreen
wait five to ten minutes for your sunscreen to
settle down and form this even layer before you
start putting on your makeup and that little wait
time means that your sunscreen is less likely to
get removed when you start putting on your makeup
do reapply sunscreen sunscreen gets less effective
over time it's just like foundation when it's on
your skin it starts clumping up as time goes on
and so you don't end up with that even layer that
you need anymore these gaps in your sunscreen
layer means that the sun can get through and
reach your skin sunscreen can also get wiped off
onto anything that it brushes against so your hair
your hands your clothes so if you put on
sunscreen in the morning and then you plan
to go to the beach in the afternoon you need to
reapply your sunscreen before you go to the beach
if you're out in the sun for an extended
period of time you should be reapplying
your sunscreen about every two hours and
you should be reapplying after you get
wet so for example if you're sweating a lot
or if you go swimming i have another video
that goes into detail about different ways of
reapplying sunscreen especially over makeup
my favorite way is to use a puff applicator and
patting on very gently over my makeup and i found
that this if i use the right sunscreen and if i'm
really gentle it mostly doesn't mess up my makeup
now for a don't - don't rely on the sunscreen
in your makeup so remember how you need
enough sunscreen for it to be effective
and remember how that means you need a
quarter teaspoon or two finger lengths
well you're not going to put on that much makeup
so a foundation with spf in it isn't enough
and a powder with spf in it definitely isn't
enough you're going to need a proper sunscreen
don't mix makeup into your sunscreen it's really
tempting to mix sunscreen and foundation in your
hand to make like a diy tinted sunscreen and so
that way you only have to put on one layer but
this is not a good idea for a sunscreen to work
well it has to form an even continuous layer on
your skin you aren't going to be able to mix
these products as evenly as a machine and so
you won't get even coverage you'll also change
how the sunscreen applies and dries on your skin
and so you'll end up with a layer that won't dry
the way that the manufacturers intended it to dry
and you'll end up with uneven coverage and
spots where you don't have enough protection
if you do want to just apply everything in one
step then look for a proper tinted sunscreen
but remember that you still need to
apply enough of it for it to be effective
so look for one that isn't super pigmented
don't use expired sunscreen sunscreen is one
of the few skincare products where
you can have really bad consequences
if it isn't working properly anymore
which is what happens when it expires
it's best to play it safe and buy a new sunscreen
if your old sunscreen is past the expiry date
also don't store your sunscreen in the heat
sunscreens will break down and separate if
it's exposed to too much heat that means
it won't spread right on your skin and so
it won't give you that even protection that
you need and you'll get gaps in your coverage
places like your car glove box are not a good
place to keep your sunscreen if you do want to
have a sunscreen with you keep it in your handbag
when you're at the beach as well make sure you
don't just leave the sunscreen bottle lying in
the sun cover it up and leave it in the shade
do make sure you pick a sunscreen that you
enjoy when you choose a sunscreen the most
important thing is to choose a sunscreen
that you'll actually use if it just lies
around sitting on the shelf after you've used
it once and you hate it then there's no point
because everyone's so much more knowledgeable
about sun protection these days there's been
a lot of really nicely textured sunscreens that
have been launched onto the market and so don't
think that all sunscreens are like heavy greasy
body sunscreens there are lots of sunscreens that
go on like primer or moisturizer in terms of
chemical versus physical sunscreens i've done
another video on the differences between them
and the pros and cons of each one but in short
there are great sunscreens in both categories the
best sunscreen for you is going to depend on what
you want in a sunscreen and what your skin is
like as a very general rule of thumb if your
biggest problem with sunscreen so far is texture
i recommend trying out a chemical sunscreen first
and if your biggest problem is irritation i'd
recommend trying out a physical sunscreen first
now on to some sunscreen recommendations like
i said earlier i have oily skin and so when
i'm looking for a sunscreen i tend to go for
really light textures i'm also really prone to
hyperpigmentation from sun damage on my dad's
side we have lots and lots of sunspots and so
i look for really high uva protection so
most of my favorites are chemical sunscreens
adore beauty stock a lot of sunscreens and that
includes one of my favorite sunscreen brands ultra
violette ultra violette are an australian brand
and they focus on making sunscreens with really
nice textures they work well under makeup and
they still give that high protection that we're
all looking for in australia my favorite of their
sunscreens is the supreme screen so this is the
one with the yellow cap it comes in a nice pump i
really like pumps because they're so convenient to
use it's very lightweight and it feels like it
sinks in very quickly it leaves a silky texture
on your skin it makes a really good makeup base it
has a primer-like finish and when you put makeup
on top it doesn't ball up which is sometimes quite
hard to find this has some of the newer generation
organic filters like tinosorb s and tinosorb m
and these give really good protection in that
uva range that i care about with my sunspots if
you like mineral sunscreens their lean screen is
one of the least white casty sunscreens i've
ever tried and some darker skin people have
tried it too and it has a pretty good texture for
a mineral sunscreen so it's not super super heavy
so one of my faves which i think you might have
just spoken about michelle is the ultra violette
lean screen which is a mineral sunscreen i've
got dry to normal skin and i was expecting this
to be a lot thicker than it actually is i actually
found it really pleasant to use and to be honest
the fragrance free part is probably the best
part because i think a lot of people find that
um quite frustrating when looking for a sunscreen
because that smell kind of hangs around on your
skin all day but this one just blends into the
skin beautifully and on dry skin totally fine
i haven't had an issue with it um in terms of
pilling i know that um that has come up with a
few people um when i've been talking about it
and i actually had an experience with pilling
with this product but i realized that it was
actually the serum that i was using underneath
it that was the problem and once i eliminated
that serum we were like good to go if you are
a lot drier and you're finding that when you're
up when you are blending it out with your fingers
that you're getting that pilling try using a
moisturizer underneath because that worked for
me as well using something a bit more hydrating
underneath and then popping this over the top
and helped with the pilling for me so
that's my tips when it comes to lean screen
another sunscreen i really love from adore beauty
is the aspect sun envirostat face spf 50. this is
a chemical sunscreen and unusually for a face
sunscreen it has four hours water resistance
it's a bit thicker than the sunscreens i usually
use but it's not super thick it's not greasy
and so it is the most comfortable water resistant
sunscreen i've ever used one issue i tend to have
with sunscreens especially with water resistant
sunscreens is that because they're trying to
form that waterproof film they tend to break up
when you put on makeup so sometimes they ball
up a bit more than non-waterproof ones this
does pill a little bit when i put on makeup
but again it's the least pilly of the
water resistant sunscreens i've used
and so this is my new go-to when i know i'm
going to sweat or if i know i'm going to get
water exposure like if i'm going kayaking or
swimming the one drawback of this is that it
doesn't have those newer uva filters ideally
i'd also want to have the newer sunscreen
filters in this for better uva protection but
it is broad spectrum according to australian
regulations and so that means that the uva
projection is already pretty decently high
so my next one is going to be alpha h's
protection plus spf 50. this is a chemical
sunscreen broad spectrum protection spf 50. i have
used this sunscreen for probably about three years
and i still consistently go back to it
there's something about it it goes on
like it's tinted but then it's not tinted
but it makes your skin just look a little bit
more airbrushed i don't think that's the right
word but it just makes your skin look more even
so when you're not wearing makeup you're going to
the beach or just on a daily basis and you like to
wear makeup this is a great product i really like
it it is probably a little bit um mattifying for
a very dry skin type but for anyone else i would
say this is perfect it's a bit of an all-rounder
beautiful texture i might actually show you so
you can see it kind of comes out tinted like that
but then as you rub it in it just kind of goes
translucent so it doesn't leave i've got quite
fair skin and it doesn't leave a tint for
me so i really love that one it does kind
of smell like hay though like you've been out
feeding horses or something so i don't know
what i think it's meant to be fragrance free
but it kind of has a smell of hay just fyi
i also really like the skinceuticals
ultra facial defense spf 50 plus
this sunscreen uses a lot of those filters
that tend to give higher protection so it
has tinosorb s mexoryl sx and xl and uvinul a plus
this sunscreen is a combo sunscreen so it also has
titanium dioxide titanium dioxide tends to give
a white cast on my skin so this one going on has
that white cast but it actually fades away
pretty quickly after the layer settles down
it is a little bit dewy and sticky on my
skin especially because we're going into
summer and it's getting quite humid but it's
very moisturizing and it's not super greasy
my next one is probably my all-time
favorite the most expensive which is a
shame because it's a really beautiful sunscreen
especially for drier skin types um i wouldn't
suggest this one for oilier skins because
i think it'll probably cause a bit too much
dewiness um on the skin but it's the mesoestetic
light water anti-aging veil they've got quite
a few different sunscreens in their range
but oh my god the texture of this is just
stunning for a drier skin it just gives you
like the most beautiful glow blends into the
skin beautifully you know how you've got to use
quite a lot of sunscreen to actually get the full
protection this just glides on like even
if you're using a lot of it feels amazing
on the skin has a beautiful fragrance as well
and it is great for more mature skin types as
well so i really really love this one they've
also got a matte version too and they've got a
little stick version as well which you can use
for eyes and lips so i absolutely love that one
as well and these three will probably just
be in my collection for the rest of my life
have you tried any of these sunscreens before or
do you have a really good sunscreen recommendation
especially a water resistant one because i'm
always looking for better water resistant
sunscreens let me know in the comments i hope you
liked this video if you did give it a thumbs up
and subscribe you can also follow me on instagram
and check out my blog for more beauty science
you can also follow adore beauty for more on all
things beauty see you next time to nerd out more